okay so in chainsaw man there's been a
ton of religious symbolism ranging from
paintings to crucifixes to literal
angels and today we're about to break
down how these biblical Clues can help
us solve the biggest mysteries in the
series during this video I'll be piecing
together evidence from the manga to
explain the true origin of all Devils
Vegeta's real identity and the meaning
behind makama's decorations along the
way we'll also explain how the
personality of certain Devils was
influenced by Christian mythology but
before we dive into it just know that
there will be some manga spoilers ahead
all right so the core of this Theory
begins with the angel devil who's the
one character that can help us link all
the evidence together if you're watching
this video you're probably aware that
each devil and Chainsaw man represents
something humans are afraid of and in
Angel's case he represents the Angels
we're used to hearing about in
Christianity within the Bible one of the
main roles of these Supernatural Spirits
is to communicate messages from God and
when we look into it the word Angel
literally translates to messenger when
it comes to the angel devil he's played
the role of messenger on a couple of
occasions in that he's delivered
important messages to the audience
directly from the author himself the
most obvious example of what I mean came
in chapter 53 in which Fujimoto used his
messenger devil to fundamentally change
our understanding of the Chainsaw man
Universe up until that chapter all we
knew about this world is that it's an
alternate version of Earth where devils
live alongside Humanity beyond that our
knowledge of this universe was virtually
nothing but in chapter 53 Angel opened
her eyes when he revealed the existence
of a place called hell I'm sure most of
you watching would agree that it can't
be a coincidence that angel the
character with the most blatant
connection to Christianity was the one
chosen to explain that hell is a real
Dimension personally I think the reason
Fujimoto chose him to say this message
was to demonstrate that angel could be
trusted when it came to biblical topics
and when the story then physically took
us to Hell later on it proved that
everything he was saying was correct
bearing that in mind a major detail in
the manga that was super easy to miss is
that in chapter 49 Angel already
confirmed that heaven exists as well in
this scene a dying woman reaches out to
him during our final moments and he then
bends down holds her hand and says to
her it's okay you're going to heaven if
any other character has said those words
honestly I wouldn't really have cared
but for the angel devil to say it
someone whose name has links to both
Heaven and Hell and someone who revealed
that one of those Dimensions is already
real we need to take it seriously if we
assume for a second the angel is
foreshadowing heaven in the same way he
foreshadowed hell then this generally
helps to explain all the Mysteries we
spoke about in the intro starting off
with the meaning behind makama's
painting in chapter 81 we saw that
inside her apartment was an illustration
from French artist Gustav dor the name
of this painting is the fall of Lucifer
and it depicts Satan being cast out of
heaven and making his way down to earth
what makes this backstory especially
interesting is that in the Book of
Revelations it describes how when Satan
fell from heaven there were a huge
amount of angels who decided to follow
him to be specific the passage explains
how one third of stars in the night sky
were flung to Earth referring to the
fact that a third of the Angels chose to
rebel against God and follow Satan
instead these Fallen Angels were
referred to in the Bible as demons which
is a phrase that could easily be
replaced by the word devils and they
were the ones who chose to side with
Lucifer in the war against the Creator
on top of that makima having this
painting became even more suspicious
when we remember that in the very next
chapter she said how she and angel had
differences in faith at the time that
chapter came out we had no idea what
differences in faith could mean but
obviously if the Fallen Angels were on
the side of Satan while the good Angels
would put their faith in God then the
picture starts to become clearer when we
met Angel for the first time he'd lost
all memories of his previous life but
thanks to makama we know that he
couldn't have been a follower of Satan
because in chapter 83 she confirmed that
he was a follower of Chainsaw man this
is what brings us to the most important
part of the theory which is the reveal
of pachita's real identity and the
reason why he's so powerful to begin
something you need to know is that
within Christian mythology angels in
heaven are divided into nine separate
rankings each of those rankings has its
own unique name and what's amazing is
that when we look at the followers of
Chainsaw man all of their names are
directly connected for instance the
highest ranked angels in the Bible are
the seraphim who were the ones closest
to God and in this panel it's the devil
called seraphim who was the one closest
to denji and makima as you can see
seraphim is also the only we want to
change the man's followers who doesn't
seem to be broken in some way
demonstrating that he is the strongest
in the group if we then switch over to
the opposite side of the hallway the
angel devil represents the two weakest
ranks in heaven which are the Angels and
the archangels this Choice was a very
calculated move from Fujimoto because in
heaven Angels and Archangels are the
ones who interact the most with Humanity
that's why the angel devil was able to
fall in love with a human make friends
with humans and was described by
katakashibe as a unique case who isn't
hostile towards them since you know he
literally represents the Angels who are
closest to mankind anyway sitting to the
right of him in the hallway is princy
the spider devil who represents the
Angelic order of principalities
otherwise known as the ranking just
above archangels next to her is power
who represents a group of warrior angels
known as powers and in the mythology
these Angels were tasked with fighting
demons which explains a lot about
power's personality according to makima
the name of the Headless devil next to
power is virtues which as you probably
guessed by now is the name of the Angels
who rank above the ones we've already
mentioned in fact as you go through each
follower of Chainsaw man from left to
right they all have names that are
derived in some way from the hierarchy
of angels and they're ordered from
lowest ranking to highest ranking in
exactly the same way this evidence
strongly implies that petite's true
identity is in some way connected to
heaven and on the next page makima said
that his followers had been waiting for
the day of his resurrection the use of
the word Resurrection was such an
intentional decision since that word is
very commonly associated with the Son of
God Jesus Christ Fujimoto has referenced
Jesus's resurrection on several
occasions like in chapter 62 when denji
is killed while in a crucifix position
only to then come back to life a couple
chapters later crucifix imagery is also
featured very heavily towards the end of
part one of the manga where we got this
moment of patita literally crouching on
top of one however the parallels don't
even stop there because in one of the
anime endings there's a holy painting of
makama holding chainsaw man in the same
way that Jesus was held by the Virgin
Mary the famous painting on the right
was designed hundreds of years ago by
Michelangelo and when you look at the
images side by side it could it be more
obvious what the anime is trying to tell
us based on all the clues we've
discussed and the clues we're about to
discuss for me there's no doubt that in
this universe Vegeta's true identity is
the son of the Creator if you're somehow
still not convinced consider that in
chapter 84 we discovered that chainsaw
man has the god-like ability to rewrite
the universe whenever pachita eats a
devil the thing that devil represents
vanishes from reality and the timeline
gets Rewritten as if it never existed in
the first place an example of this is
how one time he ate the Nazi devil and
now in the present day none of the
characters have ever heard of them
another example is how he ate the
nuclear weapons devil resulting in a
brand new timeline where the Soviet
Union never collapsed as makima said
pachita's ability is so overpowered that
not only does it manipulate history but
he Alters people's memories so that no
one remembers how things used to be
realistically there's no way a simple
chainsaw devil should be this strong
because the ability to mold the Universe
goes Way Beyond anything we could
reasonably expect to me this Godlike
power confirms the idea that pachita is
either the creator of the universe or
more likely the son of the creator
making him the equivalent to Jesus what
I'm gonna do now is explain to you my
theory on how a Jesus type character
would end up becoming chainsaw man but
before we get into it don't forget to
subscribe to the channel if you've
enjoyed the theory so far and drop a
like as it does help out the video
okay so what I think is going on here is
that wild fridge motor has taken
inspiration from various religious
Concepts he's still adding his own twist
to each idea this is evident from his
unique interpretation of Hell The Four
Horsemen and other quirky choices that
deviate from Christianity meaning this
manga will never follow the Bible
exactly that being said there are still
clues in the anime that help us get a
rough idea of events and my suspicion is
that in the beginning of the Chainsaw
man timeline the only two Dimensions
were Heaven and Earth in heaven you had
the Creator who was able to alter
reality in whatever way he wanted and
alongside him were a hierarchy of angels
who were given free will at some point
the most powerful Angel Lucifer decided
that he was worthy of taking God's power
for himself leading to the first of two
Wars between the angels on team Satan
there was one third of Heaven's
population including makima and her
sisters who at the time would not have
had the powers they have today meanwhile
on the holy side of the conflict you add
all the remaining characters we saw in
the hallway like Angel all power and
princy and together they were able to
defeat Satan and cast out his followers
from Heaven the Fallen Angels then
crashed to Earth where they became known
as Devils and my theory is that this is
when Lucifer created his weird version
of hell my reasoning for this is that
when they were banished from Heaven it
was a time when God's influence on Earth
was literally everywhere so it's logical
that Satan would have wanted or needed
somewhere to regather his forces as a
result Lucifer who we've already
established was the strongest Angel was
able to create a dimension that was the
inverse of Heaven importantly this hell
the Mansion could only be accessed by
Devils or humans who've sinned making it
impossible for the good angels in heaven
to get in later on this will explain why
pachita and his followers had to do the
unthinkable and become Devils but before
we get into that we need to talk about
how Satan would have improved his forces
in preparation for a second war the
devil naturally had to do something to
make his army more powerful and the
first step was to corrupt Humanity the
anime ending for episode 5 references
this when we see a hand Crusher golden
apple and this is a foreshadow of one of
Lucifer's most calculated decisions in
the present day we all know that Devils
get their strength from the fear of
humans but back in the beginning of time
fear didn't even exist in the Garden of
Eden inside this paradise created by God
Adam and Eve had literally nothing to be
afraid of and without fear the Fallen
Angels would have been incredibly weak
compared to today somewhere along the
line Satan must have realized that fear
could be a potential power source for
the devils and so we snuck into the
garden and tempted Eve to eat the golden
apple by giving in to his temptation she
introduced sin to the human race and it
was directly because of that sin that
Adam said he felt fear for the first
time over the following centuries
Humanity would develop countless more
fears after being banished from the
garden such as fear of hunger fear of
war and fear of the dark as humans
became more and more corrupted the
devils in Hell became more powerful and
over time they each embodied one fear
that represented them best in makima's
case she turned into the troll devil and
gained all the abilities that come with
that while Lucifer also would have
renounced his old name to become
something new my opinion on this is that
he probably became the death devil given
that death is the thing that everyone is
most afraid of whether it's fear of your
own death or the death of a relative or
the death of a pet the fact is all of us
have someone or something that we don't
want to die if I'm correct and Lucifer
really is the death devil then that
would make him the fourth Horseman of
the Apocalypse or to put it another way
he's the older sibling of the control
devil War devil and famine devil that in
itself would be a massive reveal but
what makes it crazier is that based on
fujimoto's track record there's the
undeniable possibility that death is not
a man but instead has the appearance of
a young woman ultimately she's gonna be
the final boss villain that denji has to
face and the anime even alludes to this
in this screenshot where we see a
chainsaw Angel surrounded by the Grim
Reaper this type of Angel here most
closely resembles Thrones who were one
of the highest ranking angels in heaven
and the fact we see potatoes rip put
behind it implies that at some stage
denji might gain access to more Angelic
Powers if that happens he'd be
significantly more capable of facing off
against death but as he is right now in
all likelihood he doesn't really stand a
chance anyways to explain how Satan
failed in her original plan we need to
take a look at chapter 118. in that
chapter we found out that the four
horsemen no longer have a good
relationship with yoru describing family
as crazy and confirming that they hadn't
seen each other in years additionally
Malcolm implied that if she could
rewrite reality she'd use it to erase
her three siblings from existence
judging from this we can assume that
something bad must have happened to
destroy their faith and unsurprisingly
it can all be traced back to chainsaw
man earlier on we spoke about how his
ability allows him to alter everyone's
memories but what I didn't mention is
that the four horsemen are partly immune
on at least two occasions we've seen how
the war devil and control devil still
remember things that pachita has erased
even when no one else in the universe
seems to be able to while the majority
of humans and Devils have no
recollection of the old timelines the
horsemen is seemingly one of the few who
can remember how the world used to be
because of that my guess is that seeing
his godly power in action caused makima
and famine to abandon their older sister
because in pachita they found a devil
who was somehow stronger than death
itself this would nicely explain why
makima constantly mentions how she's a
fan of Chainsaw man and was desperate to
have his immense power under her control
in fami's case she's currently
undercover in the chainsaw man fan club
and has a suspicious fascination with
denji while yoro seems more interested
in getting revenge than anything else
this obvious divide in the family likely
began in the early 1980s which is when
the second war between the Angels took
place for thousands of years death had
polluted Humanity with millions of new
fears and after two world wars in the
invention of nuclear weapons the 80s saw
Humanity on the brink of annihilating
itself all of this fear meant that death
had successfully diminished God's
influence on the earth and in the 80s
the strength of hell wouldn't have been
at its peak at the same time up in
heaven something we need to acknowledge
is that from the start God has always
respected the concept of Free Will as an
example he gave the Angels Free Will
despite knowing it could lead to a
rebellion against him and he gave Adam
and Eve a choice not to eat the apple
rather than simply programming them to
do what he wanted clearly in one way or
another he wanted his Creations to make
their own decisions so it makes sense
why he didn't intervene as Humanity
became more and more corrupted however
with that Army now ready for war against
Heaven I think that was the time where
both he and the angels realized he'd
made a mistake to fix what he'd done the
Creator gave his son the power to
rewrite reality and permanently delete
Devils from existence by consuming them
with this ability pachita could keep
altering the timeline with each devil he
erased until eventually humans would
forget the influence that Satan had for
thousands of years for me this is the
most rational explanation for petite's
insane abilities and the Godlike imagery
surrounding him but one thing it doesn't
explain is how he became a devil earlier
we established that only fallen angels
are allowed to enter hell making it a
place where Satan's Army was constantly
protected therefore Vegeta wanted to
defeat death his two options were to
either wait for Satan's Army to attack
heaven or launch his own attack against
hell of course the problem with option
number two is that to infiltrate hell
you need to sin because only then can
you truly become a devil in chapter 41
Angel confirms this when he says that
he's now a devil first and an Angel
Second indicating that the
transformation permanently Alters their
physiology anyhow back in the 1980s
pachita and his followers willingly made
a transition into Fallen Angels where
they each chose one fear they wanted to
represent for whatever reason Prince he
chose spiders golgali chose violence
power chose blood and Angel chose Angels
while the Son of God decided to pick
chainsaws it's hard to know exactly what
about chainsaws was so appealing but
considering that petite's mission was to
Massacre devils in hell he likely wanted
to embody something that would make
doing that a lot easier also with the
taxi is Chainsaw Massacre being released
in cinemas only a few years earlier it's
feasible that fujimoto's version of
Jesus just really enjoyed the movie
after becoming Devil's team chainsaw man
were then able to burst into owl where
they immediately began erasing dozens of
Fallen Angels during this massacre
pachita wiped out the nuclear weapons
devil the AIDS devil The Sixth Sense
devil and the World War II devil and
with each devil that could eaten the
Talon would rewrite itself so that those
fears never existed this massacre is
referenced in the anime itself where in
episode 2 we saw another one of dwar's
paintings in which a demon tortures a
sinner who's trying to escape from Hell
the painting is seen for a second time
in the opening shot of the intro just as
denji pulls his ripcord and to me this
symbolizes the chainsaw devil punishing
the Fallen Angels who'd corrupted
Humanity from his point of view the
Devils that he was erasing were Sinners
and just like how it's the Demon's job
in this painting to punish humans the
chainsaw man it's his job to eradicate
the Devils themselves as all of these
fears disappeared from human
consciousness one by one it's a fact
that Satan's Army would have gotten
significantly weaker since humans would
naturally begin to feel less afraid an
embarrassing defeat like that is likely
what led to the rest of the Devils
losing faith in her and it's why the
four horsemen split up to do their own
thing remember positive said in chapter
97 that makama always wanted a family
implying that the relationship she had
with her siblings wasn't really that
special in the first place following
that chainsaw Mass spent an unknown
amount of time eating more and more
Devils until he one day accidentally
messed up the timeline if we look back
at chapter 84 again makima said that
there used to be four conclusions other
than death at the end of living beans
lifespans but when chainsaw man erased
those possibilities it led to the
current situation where Devils respawn
on Earth after they die we know for
certain that in previous timelines
Devils didn't used to physically
manifest on earth like this and I can
say that for sure because some of those
old timelines were the same as ours
before pachita erased them therefore it
was likely a result of his meddling with
reality that humans and Devils ended up
in their current situation and in 1984
makama decided that she wanted to mow
the universe the way she wanted for
those of you who haven't seen my 1984
Theory then click the link on screen as
that will explain pretty much everything
that happened between that year and the
present day but for everyone else that's
pretty much it for this video I suppose
the one lingering question about all of
this is where the death devil has been
since the second war between the Angels
but personally if I had to guess I'd say
she's been in hiding and her main goal
right now should be to rewrite the
timeline again to make it so that
chainsaw man never existed it's possible
that either Yoshida or Fami are helping
her with this because it's still unclear
exactly what their motivations are but
let me know what you think in the
comments down below lastly if you
enjoyed the video then don't forget to
subscribe for more theories and
explanations like this and as always I'd
appreciate if you hit the like button as
well and share the video if you're
feeling generous thanks for watching as
always and until the next one peace out